what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really big news
not just coming from Marvel Studios but
actually coming from Disney and
specifically Disney's CEO Bob Iger and
in fact a lot of things are happening
today it looks like Marvel is in for a
pretty big change up a change up that
might be really good news to some fans
while at the same time might be
disappointing some other fans just a
little bit but overall I think what
Marvel Studios and Disney is about to do
is going to be better for the MCU for
the movies for the shows and for the
stories especially for the people who
have been stating that it's rather hard
to keep up to date with the MCU nowadays
because there's just so much to keep up
with especially if you don't want to
watch a particular show it could be kind
of annoying to some people that don't
want to watch those particular shows
because it's the MCU everything's
connected and you kind of have to watch
those shows to know what's going on so
people who are in that category should
be feeling a little bit better after
today's video however there is also a
little bit of trouble going on out there
today as the actors have now called a
strike so the writers and the actors are
on strike right now we'll talk about
what that means in this video but first
let's go over what Bob Iger said and if
you are a fan of the MCU be sure to
subscribe to the channel and hit that
notification Bell so you can stay up to
date on everything that is happening
with the MCU so this actually took place
today while Bob Iger Disney CEO was
talking to CNBC and this is the actual
headline for the CNBC article that
states Disney pulling back on making
Marvel Star Wars content Iger says the
article starts off by stating Disney is
slowing down when it comes to making
movies and TV series for its Marvel
Studios and lucasfilm franchises CEO Bob
Iger said Thursday on CNBC now we knew
this was coming both Bob Iger and Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios
did say that we're going to see a change
in the release patterns for the Disney
Plus shows and movies and when Kevin
feige was specifically asked about this
whether it was going to be fewer Disney
Plus shows or them simply spread out
more with their release dates he said
both now Bob Iger explains that there
are several reasons for this decision
and one of them is actually cost he
stated and I quote you pull back not
just to focus but also as part of our
Cost Containment initiative spending
Less on what we make and making less now
that right there is a little bit of a
concerning statement Bob Iger just said
that they are going to make less meaning
for Star Wars and Marvel they are going
to make less I would assume Disney Plus
shows movies have been pretty steady
three movies a year four movies a year
that's not too different than what
Marvel Studios was doing in the past two
to three movies a year but the Disney
Plus shows have been cranked out like
crazy so when Bob Iger talks about
making less I'm assuming he is talking
about the Disney Plus show since him and
Kevin feige have been talking about
making less Disney Plus shows in the
past that makes sense but then he said
spending Less on what they make meaning
they are not going to put as much money
into these Disney Plus shows than they
were before and this could be
problematic however since they are going
to be making less they will essentially
have more funds opened up and they won't
be working their workers so hard anymore
specifically the VFX teams that have
recently complained in the past they
won't have to go from Disney Plus show
to Disney Plus show to Disney Plus show
they will have time to work on things
and since there's going to be less
Disney Plus shows getting put out that
is a little bit more money per Disney
Plus show at least that is what we would
hope is going to happen however Bob Iger
just did say spending less and making
less so we'll have to wait and see on
that however he does say a lot more
while speaking with CNBC Bob Iger did
admit that the studio screwed with
audience Expectations by offering up so
much streaming content the negative
impact of that has been commercial
disappointments in theaters be it
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania not
even reaching 500 million worldwide or
disappointing openings for summer tent
poles Elemental and Indiana Jones and
the dial of Destiny and this is what Bob
Iger had to say about that there have
been some disappointments we would have
liked some of our more recent releases
to perform better it's reflective not as
a problem from a personal perspective
but I think in our Zeal to basically
grow our content significantly to serve
mostly our streaming offerings and
here's a really important part he
continues to say we ended up taxing our
people Way Beyond in terms of their time
and their focus Way Beyond where they
had been and he goes on to specifically
talk about Marvel he States Marvel's a
great example of that they had not been
in the TV business at any significant
level not only did they increase their
movie output but they ended up making a
number of television series and frankly
it diluted focus and tension that is I
think more of the cause than anything so
Bob Iger admits right here he states
that he believes they made so much that
it essentially diluted Marvel and the
MCU there was so much content out there
that it was almost impossible for every
individual person to maintain their
focus and attention on the MCU because
there was just so much now I know the
fandom is kind of mixed about this some
people love all of the output that
Disney has been doing with Marvel
Studios and the Disney Plus shows and
the movies and some people don't like it
so much go ahead and let us know where
you're at in the comments down below did
you think it was too much or did you
think it was fine now earlier this year
in an investor conference Bob Iger said
that there was nothing inherently off
about the Marvel Brand and I would have
to agree with that I think they just put
out way too much content for a lot of
people to keep up with even people that
I personally know who love Marvel have
said yeah it is a lot and I haven't
watched everything because it's just so
much and now I'm behind and don't really
know what's going on but for the people
who feel that way it's good news this is
good news Bob Iger is confirming hey
they're gonna make less Disney Plus
shows I hope they don't make less movies
I hope they just cut back a little bit
on the Disney Plus shows we don't need
six Disney Plus shows plus special
presentations a year but two Disney Plus
shows about really awesome characters
and one special presentation about
another awesome character a year that's
fine mix that with three movies a year
that's still a lot of Marvel content way
more than we're used to before phase
four but it wouldn't be as much to keep
up with that way the MCU could still be
fresh and it wouldn't really lose you it
wouldn't lose your attention it wouldn't
lose your focus and you could keep up
much easier now for those people who are
like me who can watch everything that
Marvel puts out unfortunately we're
going to be getting a little less
however since we are getting less
hopefully the quality does start to
increase that could be the really great
thing about Bob iger's strategy here so
that's a big change coming from Marvel
they're going to be switching up what
they do and Marvel's face 5 and phase
six could definitely be affected by this
but it is being affected right now
because of the SAG
a-f-t-r-a calls a history making strike
the SAG aftra which stands for the
Screen Actors Guild American Federation
of television and radio artists is an
American labor union representing about
a hundred and sixty thousand film and
television actors journalist radio
personalities recording artist singers
voice actors fashion models Etc and they
have caught a strike along with the
writer strike that has currently been
happening now the rider strike has
already pushed a few things with Marvel
Studios and many other Studios as well
back a little bit but now some actors
are going on strike so unfortunately
since the rider strike caused some
delays the actor strike the SAG strike
is going to be causing some more delays
hopefully this ends relatively soon
however it's not looking like it's going
to because the SAG says something very
different than what the studios are
stating the studios who are represented
by the alliance of motion picture and
television producers or the amptp they
said they presented a great and historic
deal to the SAG the representative for
them said this and I quote the amptp
presented a deal that offered historic
pay and residual increases substantially
higher caps on pension and health
contributions addition protections short
and series option periods and a
groundbreaking AI proposal that protects
actresses digital likeness for sag
a-f-t-r-a members and they concluded by
stating a strike is certainly not the
outcome we hope for as Studios cannot
operate without the performers that
bring our TV shows and films to life end
quote so the studios believe that they
offered the actors a pretty great deal
but the actors obviously do not agree so
unfortunately we don't really know when
this could possibly come to an end but
this could definitely affect Marvel
Studios especially if they have a good
amount of actors who are a part of the s
SAG
a-f-t-r-a we do know that the rider
strike did delay some of Marvel Studios
projects a little bit and although it is
not official or confirmed in any means
yet we should be expecting some more
delays due to this if they don't happen
to have any more delays that is great
but let's just prepare ourselves and in
the meantime be sure to subscribe to the
channel and hit that notification Bell
if you want to stay up to date on
everything happening with the MCU
including those release dates don't
forget to like this video and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items we pick one winner at the end of
each month and the winner gets to pick
one item you can also further support us
on patreon check out our website or join
our Discord server and of course you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
thank you